ja der der einst der chef von tengelmann
war er ist verschollen karl erivan haub
seit dem siebten april 2018 also mehr
als vier jahren fehlt jede spur von ihm
seit einer bergtour längst ist er für
tot erklärt worden das ist ein krimi
diese geschichte um diesen tengelmann
boss und dieser krimi um den tengelmann
milliardär der geht noch weiter denn vor
wenigen tagen hat jetzt ein bergsteiger
ein skelett gefunden in der matterhorn
region dort wo haupt dieser tengelmann
milliardär bergsteigen war genau dort
ist das was man dort gefunden hat dass
tengelmann skelett wir warten auf
antwort auf diese frage und sprechen
darüber mit unser bild reporter jörg
völkerling der sich auf die spuren
gemacht hat in den vergangenen tagen mal
wieder auf die spuren des tengelmann
milliardärs karl erivan haub welche
hinweise jörg so guten morgen gibt es
darauf dass das dass tengelmann skelett
ist
die antwort darauf liegt hinter mir in
der morgensonne verbogen dort steht das
matterhorn und karl erivan haub hatte ja
an dem morgen mit skiausrüstung den weg
auf das kleine matterhorn gemacht wir
können das hier nachvollziehen an der
karte er ist zur höchst gelegenen
bergstation
europas gefahren und von dort aus hatte
er mehrere möglichkeiten sozusagen wege
pisten zu nehmen und seine die leiche
die man jetzt gefunden hat lag am stock
die gletscher das ist tatsächlich auch
eine option dass er diesen weg genommen
hat deswegen ist die fantasie natürlich
angesprungen in den letzten tagen dass
es sich bei dieser offenbar recht gut
erhaltenen leiche um karl erivan haub
handelt sie liegt im moment noch in der
gerichtsmedizin und ziehen es gibt noch
keine endgültige identifizierung das
dauert ein bisschen die dna muss
verglichen werden es gibt allerdings ein
paar hinweise die sagen naja ob es
wirklich karl erivan haub war er hat
eine skiausrüstung aus den 70er jahren
dabei war hat eine jeans an all das ist
jetzt nicht unbedingt etwas was so einen
sportler wie karl erivan haub der die
partie die glacis mehrere male
mitgemacht hat wirklich angezogen hätte
also das war du sagst ein ganz
erfahrener ein ganz sportlicher
bergsteiger was macht man da jetzt noch
weiter um das herauszufinden klar die
enertec hast du gesagt dabei gibt es
auch weitere sucharbeiten dort am
matterhorn um vielleicht noch weitere
indizien weitere hinweise zu finden
ich habe gestern mit dem chef der
bergrettung an land rover gesprochen der
damals auch die rettungsmaßnahme
suchmaßnahmen
koordiniert hat und der hat ja die
leiche sozusagen geborgen die war in
einem stück die war gut erhalten
mumifiziert
suchaktionen jetzt finden in dem bereich
nicht statt allerdings in den letzten
tagen sind wieder knochen gefunden
wurden in saas fee in einem anderen
gletscher das hat natürlich mit dem
klimawandel zu tun die nullgradgrenze es
hier auf über 5000 meter gestiegen die
sommersaison wo sonst immer hier auch im
sommer gefahren werden konnte musste
abgesagt werden also da kommen natürlich
jetzt einige sachen ans licht vielleicht
lichtet sich auf die weise auch das
geheimnis um karl erivan haub um den es
ja doch noch ganz andere spekulationen
gibt um sein verschwinden ja du sagst es
spricht noch mal ein paar von diesen
verschwörungstheorien auch an dass er ja
tatsächlich ein krimi und eine ganz
besondere geschichte dieser ja einer der
reichsten männer deutschlands
verschwindet plötzlich spurlos also
natürlich auch immer wieder die
geschichte der ist einfach abgetaucht er
hat sich neues leben gesucht
ja die familie haub ist natürlich eine
der reichsten familien deutschlands über
vier milliarden beträgt ihr vermögen und
die zeit in der karl erivan haub
verschwand eine sehr bewegte zeit es gab
auseinandersetzungen in diesen familien
clan der vater von karl erivan haub war
einen monat vorher verstorben es ging
natürlich um das aufteilen des erbes und
ich habe selber mit jemand aus seinem
trainings starb gesprochen damals ich
war ja mit dem kollegen sascha baumann
hier schonmal 2018 auf spurensuche und
derjenige sagte mir eigentlich karrieren
haupt wäre niemals einfach so auf gerade
wohl an einem solchen morgen alleine
aufgebrochen um da noch mal einfach
trainieren zu gehen also es war die
möglichkeit die relativ frühen spiel kam
dass er über italien nach hinten
sozusagen wie sind die hier auf der
schweizer seite einfach ins tal hinab
gefahren ist und da irgendwo sich in
luft aufgelöst hat verschwunden hat
irgendwo ein neues leben begonnen hat
und da kam natürlich dann zum beispiel
auch eine russin spiel eine
mitarbeiterin einer modelagentur und
sankt petersburg zu der offenbar
beziehungen hatte welcher art auch immer
also steht die frage im raum warum dann
auch so schnell eine todeserklärung von
der familie angestrebt wurde die schon
drei jahre danach vom amtsgericht köln
erklärt wurde also da ist vieles was
einfach noch im nebel liegt so wie das
matterhorn hier an diesem morgen und
möglicherweise verzieht sich ein
bisschen von diesem nebel in den
nächsten stunden wenn dann die dna dort
gecheckt ist und wir wissen ist es das
tengelmann skeletten oder ist es das
nicht dann kann unser bild reporter jörg
völkerling dort an den fuß des
matterhorns tolle bilder hinter dir
[Musik]